Cape Town is one of the most beautiful
cities in the world it's also one of the
most dangerous we're taking a closer
look at a wave of deadly violence
sweeping across Cape Town South Africa a
lethal mix of journalists and guns has
caused a surge in the murder rate
certainly in many areas there is a
crisis the letters has been thinking as
the boiling kettle and it's boiling over
last year more than three thousand
people were murdered here the number has
doubled in a decade in some areas the
situation is so volatile that emergency
services refuse to enter how did Kate
tell reached crisis point
[Music]
so guys we just cannot proceed to the
update of the weekend but seven people
were shot five whales one female in one
posture Kraven Engle runs a pioneering
project called ceasefire based in one of
the most violent areas of the city
Hanover Park it every hour where
civilians get shot disconnect but do
anymore
Kraven and his team monitor gang
violence in the district and where
possible step in to calm things down
well a budget they can easily be like 17
incidents of violence in the area and
multiple shots of more than about 60
shots fired yeah the team is made up of
reformed gang members we started out by
using guys that we recruited from the
street and we help them to recover it
trained them strategically to come out
their own kind then known as the
interrupters the violence interrupter is
at the front end of the violence but it
must also be a credible message in the
community and credible with the gangs
just down here we had a shooting here
about five minutes ago and they another
club you fired the interruptive use a
technology called shot spotter its
employees sophisticated acoustic sensors
set up across the area to detect and
locate gunfire incidents in real time a
shot coming in now we can go through the
area which we find and this is our
region of community our shots get fired
into happen
life goes one is normal Craven's project
is based in an area of the city known as
the Cape Flats a patchwork of townships
southeast of the city center last year
nearly 2,500 people were murdered in
these townships almost 80 percent of the
city's total homicides in other parts of
Cape Town you know particularly the
wealthier and middle-class areas the
murder rate has remained relatively
stable wars non-existent it's highly
unequal in terms of a distribution of
murder it's been estimated that there
are 93 gangs in Cape Town with 100,000
members these criminal gangs are
particularly well organized but also a
particularly violent they are rooted
into the community with a system set in
place what's been happening in Captain
in the past few years has been an
intensification and gang conflict
over the past decade this conflict has
been fueled by deadly weapons the key
issue in South Africa in terms of the
murder rate has been the influx of
high-powered firearms into capital many
of these guns aren't coming from
criminal networks but from the police in
2016
Chris Prinsloo a former police colonel
pleaded guilty to selling 2400 guns to
an arms dealer who sold them on to
gangsters
it's involved in specific gangs and
those gangs then started to take on
others and rarely escalated the gang
conflict to the stage of a wolf
investigators have linked more than a
thousand murders to these firearms
including 261 cases in which children
were victims under previous President
Jacob Zuma police corruption became
endemic on the ground
gangs recruit corrupt officers who
provide tips about raids this is taking
place in the context of high-level
corruption senior police officials
indicate that there has been some form
of collusion between individuals within
the ruling party and those in the
command award in Cape Town the murder
rate has risen from 44 to 73 people per
100,000 in ten years it's now more than
twice that of Johannesburg one study
found it was the 11th most murderous
city in the world not including places
that are too chaotic to count the bodies
the crisis in Cape Town is a result of a
toxic mix of factors the roots of which
go back more than half a century
violence in captain also has
particularly strong historical driving
factors the city is particularly divided
socially and spatially in the 1960s the
apartheid regime forcibly removed two
mixed-race people known in South Africa
as coloured from the inner city centre
the forced removals saw them being
dumped and her flats and having to
establish new communities police rarely
investigated the murders of people who
weren't white then elect allowed
criminals to terrorize these black and
colored townships in these particular
contexts you saw gangs flourish
conditions and many of these communities
haven't changed that much today the area
still suffers deep-rooted socio-economic
problems in one precinct philippi East
93% of households were victims of crime
in 2016 you can never cluster so much
people in such a small space together
with no economic development would no
recreation with no job creation at DISA
people self-destruction 40% of young
South Africans are unemployed President
Cyril Ramaphosa calls it a national
crisis apart they destroy everything in
its own way the white only sign is
disappeared but the violence the
negativity the opportunities nothing has
come the way of this community
[Music]
Gordon was in a gang from the age of 12
after spending almost a decade in prison
he left the gang seven years ago to
become an interrupter for ceasefire like
our mother today he's returned to the
township where he grew up
this is my wall this is reai come from
you can see has no opportunities no
probabilities no nothing the only
survivor key inside of us be against
them become a drag do you know in the
age of 12 years old they shot where one
brother be in front and the one they
shot him inside and I divided our ID is
where I did my first murder we grew up
what the out of stone like we got
nothing to lose when he was a gangster
it was his job to recruit children to
join his gang known as the Mongols this
is the only way to make that game
continue to recruit kids you know but
since he started working for ceasefire
he's focused on preventing children from
getting involved in gang culture now
rolling with these little kids just want
to be example there you make them
believe you don't need to be a gangster
drug dealer or a kiddy you can travel
the world I can be the example you know
it's so example but all the kids you
know it won't be amazing
ceasefire this so far helps 700
gangsters like Gordon to leave their old
life
mine and become community activists but
there's only so much a small charity can
do like ourselves in many others make a
dent but that dent was soon
you know disappear ceasefire is is one
of the tools for bringing down violence
and it can be particularly effective if
it's linked to other sorts of
interventions the problem certainly in
Cape Town is that there has been an
absence of those sort of interventions
that have been scattered across the city
and so there aren't particularly
effective South African authorities are
taking steps to tackle the crisis in
2018 they set up a specialized anti-gang
unit tasked with bringing down violent
gang crime in the city last year with
the death toll escalating they even sent
the army onto the streets of Cape Flats
and a mr. Ram opposer the South African
government is also trying to replace
corrupt police and prosecutors with
clean ones yet the murder rate continues
to rise bringing in or an order to a
place like Cape Flats will take time
South Africa is continually creating
perpetrators of violence particularly
young men who will use violence against
each other or use violence and intimate
relationships against their wives
against their girlfriends against their
children we need to do something very
seriously about trying to prevent
violence against children and work with
families particularly families that are
at high risk of this violence happening
South Africa needs more jobs better
policing and a cultural shift among
young men apartheid left a legacy of
violent
it may take south-africa decades to
overcome it if you enjoyed this film and
want to see more then take a look at our
film on Mandela's legacy in South Africa
you can find that linked in the
description below for more economist
coverage then click the link opposite
for our special report on Africa finally
- stay tuned for more economist films
click Subscribe
thanks for watching
you